we just got the first awesome trailer
for Black Panther which gives us a
glorious peek inside the world of
Wakanda and a first look at new villains
in the MCU ebk movie lovers it's Jan
here and in this video I'm breaking down
the Black Panther trailer for Easter
eggs references and other teasers of
what we can look forward to seeing in
the movie the trailer kicks off with the
return of Ulysses Klaw and he's missing
his left arm which you'll probably
remember he lost when ultron cutted off
an avengers age of ultron Klaw was
stockpiling vibranium which he sold to
Ultron in that movie and here he's being
interrogated by Everett Ross the CIA
asked who appeared for the first time in
Captain America Civil War in the comics
Klaw also loses a limb and get the
prosthetic arm equipped with a sonic
emitter that he uses as a weapon and
I'll talk more about that later by the
way I'm sure it won't be lost on fans of
The Hobbit that thanks to this scene
we're seeing Bilbo Baggins and Gollum
together again next up is this misty
shot of an enormous waterfall which
reminded me of the last time we saw
Black Panther in the mid credit scene
for Captain America Civil War we're to
Charlotte and Steve Rogers looked out
over a jungle landscape with a waterfall
in the distance this is actually warrior
Falls and in the following shot we'll
see two charla emerging from his royal
talon fighter for his coronation
ceremony you no doubt noticed a child as
fantastic tattoos he steps out his craft
and it's a little difficult to see here
but they're actually Panther themed and
greeting T'Challa for the ceremony is
Forest Whitaker who's playing luery a
spiritual leader and a father-like
figure to T'Challa director Ryan Coogler
has described Zoe as an obi-wan Kenobi
type character who will advise and guide
Black Panther in the movie and with Zuri
you can also see these children
preparing for the ceremonial ritual
they're using something called a
heart-shaped herb in the comics the
juices of this herb are prepared in a
ceremony can give it only to those who
are worthy enough to become the Black
Panther the herb gives the reciever
super strength speed agility senses and
healing powers which you can see in some
of the awesome action shots in the
trailer
notice of sports for example with which
to charla slammed this guy into a truck
and The Incredible backflips in this
shot and the way black panther's
vibranium armor just deflects these
bullets reminds me of that rooftop scene
in Civil War where bullets also just
glanced off him also in the trailer we
get one of our new villains Erik to kill
monger who's actually the guy
the mask breaking claw out from his
detention with a team of mercs kill
monger is a supervillain and a powerful
nemesis of black panther and the mask is
wearing here is a bit different from the
one he has in the comics so it retains
the main around the mask Erik kill manga
is played by Michael B Jordan who worked
at Black Panther director Ryan Coogler
previously on Crede and Fruitvale
station and we can see kill manga
apprehended later in the trailer and
escorted by Wahhabi who is to Charla's
chief of security in the comics and
Wachovia's played by daniel Kaluga who
recently starred in the horror movie get
out and it looks like kill manga has
been escorted to meet two charla and the
other tribal leaders in this throne room
by the way this tribal leader with a lip
plate is currently described on IMDB as
a River tribe elder there's also a
number two challahs elite female
bodyguards adorn Malaysia in the trailer
overseeing the interrogation of Klaw is
o Korea played by Danai gurira from The
Walking Dead and is also this very cool
group shot in the dorm aloshy headed up
by Florence combi kizomba appeared
briefly in Captain America Civil War
where she faced off with Black Widow
telling the Avenger to move or be moved
back to this trailer in the casino scene
is Nakia played by Lupita Nyong'o and
she also appears later in her dora
menagerie outfit with some cool discs
like weapons and next to Nakia is Cherie
- Charlie's sister played by Leticia
arrives and she's sporting some very
cool Panther style blasters these are
likely a vibranium based weapon that
she's developed herself because their
background in the movie is that she
spent many years researching vibranium
and developing technology which makes me
wonder if Klaw will be trying to steal
some of her tech for his weaponized
prosthetic arm nakeeran cherie also show
up again in the scene with a child's
mother Amanda this shot is set in the
mountain terrain of the Jabari tribe and
another scene introduces her leader
mbaku also known of the comics as man
ape mbaku is a powerful tribal leader
who's been a long-standing enemy of
black panther in the comics
his comic book character led the
outlawed white gorilla cult and he
obtained super-strength
after taking part in a ritual involving
a white gorilla and you can see a little
nod to that perhaps in the white fur
that he and his followers are wearing
now this is an interesting shot because
look carefully at the spokes on black
panther's color and they're definitely
different to the ones we saw him wear
and captain
America Civil War and earlier in the
trailer I'm curious as to whether this
is a flashback an early version of his
suit or perhaps his suits been damaged
and he's had to go back to an earlier
prototype so what did you think of the
Black Panther trailer and did it get you
hyped up for the movie and were there
any other Easter eggs or cool details
you noticed I'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below if you
enjoyed this you might also like my
Wonder Woman Easter eggs video where
I've got a cool giveaway for an awesome
art of the movie book and don't forget
to give this video a thumbs up if you
liked it and while you're here check out
some of my other videos by tapping or
clicking the screen thanks for watching
and see you next time you became movie
lovers